una ley que busca luchar contra el
cambio climático y la pérdida de la
biodiversidad fue aprobada por el
parlamento europeo el bloque dejará de
importar productos que provengan de
tierras deforestadas o que la provoquen
como aceite de Palma ganado vacuno soya
café caucho madera o chocolate la ley de
deforestación es ya una realidad con 552
votos a favor Europa da un paso para
luchar contra la deforestación global
así asumimos verdaderamente la
responsabilidad de nuestro consumo las
empresas que busquen Vender productos en
la Unión Europea deberán hacer una
declaración de diligencia de aportar
información verificable que demuestre
que sus insumos no se cultivaron en
terrenos donde hubo tal la
indiscriminada de no cumplir estos
requisitos enfrentarían multas hasta hoy
los estantes de nuestro supermercados
han estado llenos con demasiada
frecuencia de productos cubiertos con
las cenizas de las selvas tropicales
quemadas y los ecosistemas destruidos
irreversiblemente y que habían acabado
con los medios de subsistencia de
pueblos indígenas aunque no hay una
lista de países específica algunos ya
han elevados protesta contra la Unión
Europea como Indonesia y Malasia que son
los mayores exportadores de aceite de
Palma del mundo el bloque es el mayor
importador de este aceite la
deforestación es la responsable de al
menos un 20% de las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero la ley aún
necesita la aprobación formal de los
países europeos las empresas grandes
tendrían 18 meses para cumplir con los
requisitos y las pequeñas 24 meses